y
[Música]
la palabra con r&r mis sentimientos
tengo esta camiseta que dice terminemos
con la palabra con r porque no es bueno
usarla yo no la usen más acabemos con
los abusivos para siempre no queremos
escuchar esa palabra quítense la de la
boca y cambian la por respeto
simplemente no usen esa palabra delante
de mi cara no está bien decir eso o no
la digan en absoluto sí pero que
mantengan la boca cerrada y listo si no
no está bien decirle eso a niños con
síndrome de down o yo diría que en vez
de eso vayan y digan hola sería el
comienzo de una linda amistad no me
molesta demasiado pero cuando un amigo
te lleva a algún lado y usa malas
palabras eso a veces puede salir creo
que la gente debería prohibir esa
palabra
en lugar de decir esa que la palabra con
rsa respeto estoy en una relación
estar en una relación con mis amigos es
genial no estoy de acuerdo porque tuve
muchos ex novios y a veces quiero darme
el gusto de estar soltera la razón por
la que elegí ligeramente de acuerdo es
porque encontré el amor en alguien que
me importa y estoy muy feliz pero a
veces es difícil mantener feliz a mi
novia porque es difícil mantenerla feliz
porque a veces puede ser como cuando se
enoja es porque tiene hambre yo
personalmente tengo una novia pero le
diré a todas por ahí que sean felices de
tener lo que tienen porque
estamos aquí para ser buenos chicos y
para tener una gran relación con las
mujeres sé que es difícil para las otras
chicas saberlo pero yo
amo a mi novia
ganó mi propio dinero
vaya quería mi propio dinero por eso
conseguí un trabajo realmente le agradó
al dueño de la cafetería así que obtuve
mi propia entrevista y obtuve mi propio
trabajo para preparar bebidas y comida y
desde que salgo con él mi corazón está
muy feliz de verlo crecer es muy
gratificante ver lo que hace me
enorgullece
gracias gano mi propio dinero para ser
independiente me gusta vivir solo y hago
camisetas yo gano mi mi
dinero trabajo duro quiero ser
multimillonaria y millonaria como mujer
con síndrome de dawn siendo yo misma
hago mi dinero escribí un libro y hago
charlas públicas y además estuve
haciendo un programa de televisión
llamado así nací trabajé muy duro para
estar en la cima y eso es lo que soy soy
una mujer con una carrera muy muy
exitosa hago mi propio camino voy a lo
grande y no tiro la toalla y sigo mis
sueños es cierto los niños con
necesidades especiales tenemos sueños
que seguir no importa qué sueño sea haz
lo que puedas hacer mejor no dejes que
nadie te derribe me encanta ganarme mi
propio dinero es muy gratificante saber
que trabajo bien me hace sentir feliz y
el haber hecho un gran trabajo aunque
tengo síndrome de dawn ganó ese dinero
porque me ganó el respeto entonces las
personas que piensan que no podemos
hacerlo si podemos y somos poderosos
fuertes y podemos hacer cualquier cosa
que nos propongamos grace quieres
compartir algo al respecto
estaba haciendo esto ella está haciendo
algo de dinero algo de dinero si eso
ayuda sí muy bien yo puedo ayudarte
quiero tener hijos
no quiero tener hijos todavía quizás
cuando sienta que es el momento adecuado
si quiero tener uno lo haré pero también
sería difícil cuidarlos por mí por mi
condición ya es difícil para mí
levantarme por la mañana así que
preparar el almuerzo para mis hijos y
todo eso sería difícil entonces quiero
saber quién soy en este momento y
aprender me encantaría tener hijos
porque amo a los niños es muy divertido
jugar con ellos por ejemplo jugar con
ellos hacer cualquier cosa con ellos y
además me encantaría tener hijos y poder
prestarles atención abrazar porque todos
estamos aquí para divertirnos me gustan
mucho los bebés aunque son muchas las
responsabilidades al cuidar de un niño
entonces voy a hacer una gran madre y
les voy a enseñar a tener buenos modales
y a divertirse y también a explorar su
educación solo vine aquí para estar
acuerdo si quiero tener hijos quiero
darle una vida a mi hijo y quiero
criarlo como mío porque no quiero
depender de mi mamá para que críe ella
sola mi hijo
si quiero tener hijos porque
quiero darles la vida que me dio mi
madre puedo cuidar de mí mismo
bueno sí me cuido
soy muy buena cocinando y limpiando por
mí misma a veces no soy muy buena
manteniendo mi habitación en orden pero
sigo trabajando para lograrlo me he
vuelto independiente soy una
mujer independiente me gusta estar con
mis amigos me encanta estar con chicos
claro porque me gustan los chicos y
también me gusta mucho ir de fiesta
verás tengo mucha confianza y soy buena
vistiendo me y haciendo algunas compras
y con cosas de cuidado personal y ayudo
a la gente algo que se rían y que se
entretengan con mi comedia si algún día
voy a ser comediante
juego así que eres comediante sí así es
puedo cuidar de mí mismo tenemos que
movernos vamos por aquí
qué dices a mami yo quiero quiero quiero
quiero
ayuda españa necesita ayuda para bañarse
yo entiendo
gracias mami buen trabajo me gusta cómo
me veo
la razón por la que digo que estoy
extremadamente de acuerdo es porque me
encanta como me veo no me importa cómo
luzco sé lo que me gusta y estoy muy
feliz por eso no me importa lo que la
gente piense de mí sé que estoy el mejor
porque amo mi cuerpo yo soy hermosa soy
soy única y soy hermosa y también soy
una mujer independiente me encanta cómo
me veo porque soy
preciosa soy hermosa
fuerte y valiente porque soy serás para
mí mantenerte hermosa fuerte y segura de
ti misma te da un impulso al ver tu
apariencia en el espejo y te sientes más
segura de quién eres a mí me encanta mi
apariencia es mi personalidad como una
personalidad genial porque soy quien soy
y me amo a mí mismo en serio para mí es
realmente genial estar con mis amigos
que están aquí ahora conmigo son estos
amigos que tengo ahora mismo me hacen
sentir también porque me siento muy
poderoso miren estas armas y tengo una
gran sonrisa para mis amigos aquí mismo
no me molesta tener síndrome de dawn
[Aplausos]
estoy de acuerdo en esto porque es lo
que me hace ser yo y mis amigos no me
tratan como si fuera un niño cualquiera
con síndrome de dawn estoy feliz por
quién soy a veces mi familia me
consciente un poco pero si estoy con mis
amigos no tratan de consentir me tanto y
estoy feliz por eso entonces estoy feliz
porque ellos están felices tener
síndrome de dawn no es muy difícil para
mí solo estoy siendo quien soy y me hace
muy especial no no me molesta tener
síndrome de dawn porque no me avergüenzo
de quién soy ni de cómo me veo porque
soy una mujer hermosa con una carrera
exitosa y con confianza en los negocios
estoy muy de acuerdo con lo que soy y no
me avergüenza tengo síndrome de dawn y
me encanta quién soy porque estoy muy
agradecido conmigo mismo me quiero a mí
mismo amo estos chicos que son mis
amigos y que también tienen síndrome de
down están realmente pegados amigo ven
aquí
me gusta quedarme hasta tarde con mis
amigos me encanta festejar con mis
amigos no importa lo que haga aunque
tengo una discapacidad aún así me
divierto sin importar que así es si mi
amigo
no imposible
gran trabajo aplausos para ustedes
[Risas]
amigos